organic farming and the aftermath of the
mill quota system were the focus of the
agriculture and Fisheries come to the
gathering in Brussels on Monday March 16
the ongoing organic farming proposal
aims to review the existing legislation
on organic production I'm labeling of
products the goals are to strengthen the
development of organic production in the
EU guarantee fair competition for
farmers and improve consumer confidence
in organic goods latvia's Minister for
agriculture Janice two claps told
reporters of two chair in the meeting
that the council had a good discussion
and that the goal was to prepare ground
for the may council where ministers will
try to achieve general approach in order
to start negotiations with the European
Parliament ministers were expected to
give guidance on sensitive issues such
as the presence of pesticides as well as
other forbidden substances in organic
products they also debated the input
regime and the control systems of
organic products both of our discussions
on the import regime enabled us to
achieve considerable progress in the
development of this legislation I
believe that it is fair to consider that
all that is left to do on this issue is
just some technical adjustment as
regards controls member states have
clear stances on the extent of controls
of our own spot checks dairy was also
high on the minister's agenda as the
milk quota system that has governed the
EU market for over three decades draws
to an end in March 2015 milk quotas have
conditioned the activity of an entire
generation of dairy farmers most of whom
have never produced in an unlimited
environment as a result in some weeks
the EU mill sector will be more
market-oriented this will bring about
changes for dairy producers in a context
of price volatility and market
fluctuation the situation in the milk
market has to be followed closely
in order to be able to assess the
influence of the abolition of quotas
ministers also held a debate on the
implementation and simplification of the
Common Agricultural Policy otherwise
known as the cup finally the council was
briefed on animal welfare offered
animals following a broadcast by Dutch
TV and the publication of a report by an
animal rights organization the
Netherlands addressed the issue at
county level to prevent products
involving animal welfare malpractices
from entering the EU market